welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John watus and I'm the technical director for education at IBM Quantum
this is the 13th lesson of the series and it's the first lesson in the fourth and final unit which is on Quantum error
correction Quantum Computing has the potential to enable efficient solutions to computational tasks for which
efficient classical algorithms are not known and possibly don't exist there are however very significant challenges that
will need to be overcome if were to implement the sorts of large scale Quantum computations that we hope will one day be
possible the heart of the matter is that Quantum information is extremely fragile you can literally ruin it just by
looking at it and so to operate correctly quantum computers need to isolate the quantum information they
store from the environment around them to an extreme degree but at the same time the quantum computer itself must provide us with
very precise control over this Quantum information and that includes proper initialization accurate and reliable
unitary operations and of course the ability to perform measurements so that we can actually obtain the results of the
computation there's clearly some tension between these requirements and in the early days of quantum Computing there were some who viewed that the fragility
of quantum information and its susceptibility to both inaccuracies and environmental noise would ultimately
make Quantum Computing impossible today there's little doubt that building an accurate and reliable
large scale quantum computer is a Monumental challenge but we have a key tool to help us in this endeavor that leads most
people who are knowledgeable about the field to be optimistic about large scale Quantum Computing one day becoming a reality and that tool is quantum error
correction for the next four lessons we'll discuss Quantum error correction with a focus on the
fundamentals in this lesson we'll take a first look at Quantum error correction including one of the very first quantum
error correcting codes discovered the 9 Cubit Shore code and we'll also discuss another fundamental Concept in Quantum
error correction which is known as the discretization of errors in the subsequent lessons of the unit we'll see more sophisticated and ultimately better
Quantum error correcting code constructions and we'll also discuss the problem of quantum computation on encoded Quantum information using
computational components that are themselves not perfect and prone to errors here's a brief overview of the
lesson we'll Begin by discussing classical repetition codes which are perhaps the simplest and most basic type
of classical error correcting code classical repetition codes aren't particularly good codes by classical
coding Theory standards at least on their own but that's okay here we're going for Simplicity and in particular
we'll take a look at just about the simplest classical error correcting code you can possibly imagine which we'll then use as a basis for a simple example
of a Quantum error correcting code that example is the 9 cbit Shore code which we'll discuss in detail
including a description of the code itself as well as procedures for encoding cubits using this code detecting errors on encoded cubits and
correcting those errors and in the third part of the lesson we'll discuss the discretization of Errors which allows us to think about arbitrary errors on
cubits which in principle form a Continuum of possibilities in discrete terms essentially boiling errors down to
so-called bit flips and phase flips before we get into the Technic details of quantum error correction it's
worth taking just a moment to consider the need for Quantum error correction as well as classical error
correction as I suggested at the start of the lesson quantum computers are highly susceptible to errors owing to
the fragility of quantum information in particular unwanted interactions with the environment or in
other words the rest of the world can disturb Quantum information these unwanted interactions can cause decoherence where information
essentially leaks into the environment causing the information stored by the quantum computer to behave more and more
classically it's also critically important that we recognize that Quantum operations can only be performed with limited
accuracy for example we might wish to perform a particular Quantum gate on a cubit but because physical devices are
never perfect what we actually Implement might be just an approximation to that gate that might not be a big deal for a
single gate but if Our intention is to perform thousands or millions of quantum Gates these small inaccuracies will
start to acrew and when the computation is finished we could end up with a very different state from what we
expected so this is a rather different source of errors but it's certainly one that we can't
ignore people have been studying classical error correcting codes for close to a century and these codes have many applications including in
information transmission and storage but because classical Computing components are so reliable we we don't actually
need error correction to build classical computers now it might be the case that error correction isn't actually needed
to build reliable large scale quantum computers either for example the main idea behind topological Quantum
Computing is that it might be possible to build robust Quantum systems that are inherently protected against noise due
to topological properties of the systems but we don't know if this will be possible and it's pretty widely believed
that error correction will probably be essential in one form or another for large- scale Quantum Computing now we'll discuss classical
repetition codes which form the basis for our first Quantum error correcting code the nine cbit Shore code which
we'll see shortly repetition codes are extremely basic examples of error correcting codes
the idea is that we can protect bits against errors by simply repeating each bit some number of times in particular let's take a look at
the three-bit repetition code here we encode one bit into three by simply repeating the bit three times so
zero is encoded as 00 0 and one is encoded as 111 of course if nothing goes wrong we
can easily distinguish the two possibilities but if there was an error and one of the bits flipped let's say
meaning that a zero changes into a one or a one changes into a zero then we can still figure out what the original bit
was by seeing which of the two binary values appears twice equivalently we can decode by Computing the majority value
or in other words the binary value that appears most frequently and it's not hard to see that
if we have at most one bit flip error then the decoding will be correct of course if two bits Flip or if
all three bits flip then it won't work and we'll get the wrong value when we decode and that's a general property
that every error correcting code possesses you may be able to correct some errors but you'll never be able to correct every error and ultimately it's
about decreasing the chance of an error as opposed to guaranteeing correctness which is generally not